the end of our podcast we do unhelpful
advice so people email with problems and
and we and we can help them or not help
them all right on hopeful advice with
gila darling
hello my name is taiyo and i am 19 years
old i've been kicked out of my house by
my korean dad two weeks ago after having
several fights most of which were
resolved through violence and after
spending a few days homeless my friend's
family let me stay at their house
i can't see myself forgiving him anytime
soon i plan on not taking uh talking to
him for a very in a very long time do i
cut him out of my life completely or do
i try to talk to him again down the line
tayo i just cannot get away from koreans
huh
my god
kicked out of the house listen
my dad was
so very violent
and especially that age
from
12 to
i was in my 20s you know he was very
violent
but
things always change they you know what
what's great is he he'll change
i mean everyone changes
he'll get older right he'll do some
reflection especially when he gets older
like kind of in his 50s and 60s people
don't though some people don't some
people because my uncle carlo he's still
when he was in jail for how long like
20 15 to 20 years for uh murder killing
my other uncle
and like
philippine families are wild
but they um you know he still
anytime anyone is out of line
he puts on that threat pretty thick he's
like you know where i come from you know
what i've done why are you talking to me
like that and everyone in our family is
like oh okay like we don't cross them
because we genuinely don't think that he
has changed
yeah this is such a common korean family
dynamic like i've
i know another person who got kicked out
of the house same thing violent korean
dad
uh
but on his end on in his story he
actually rekindled forgave and they have
a great relationship now
so some people change there needs to be
space though between them absolutely
yeah they cannot it's like co-worker
lover parent it doesn't matter if
there's violence there just get the [ __ ]
out create that space between you you
can't be in the same household right
they didn't rekindle until they really
he was like very much an adult very much
an adult and it's such a common thing in
korean families the dads are
pretty
angry
yeah but they they think they calm down
later on yeah but it's it's interesting
because our culture is changing
and i think that you know
people are more sensitive that kind of
you know um
that lifestyle but um
that kind of environment you know and i
just can't believe
that that [ __ ] still goes on
especially with because you know we are
changing as a as a planet in terms of
how we feel about certain things and i i
just feel bad that must be even more
because back in my day
when i was it was like you look at other
korean kids with a black eye
and you'd be like you know that's just
what it is
it was more accepted
i mean that kind of violence you know
what i mean but i just don't know why it
still continues you know i mean but it
does i feel bad for the kid but you know
i think that if and if it doesn't change
move on with your life and just don't
repeat the behavior
yeah i don't i'm never going to hit my
kid right right ever
you know
i'm never gonna um i just also don't
think that hitting is not effective
it just is
like you know
there's no amount of like my parents
obviously like my mom hit me a lot and
stuff but it didn't change any bad
behavior she thought i was having it
made you hide it better yeah it made me
it made me a worse like
maladjusted right kid and teenager and
it made me more rebellious even
i didn't wanted i wanted i was looking
for a revenge you were hit too oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] beat out of me
but look at us now
i mean what did what happened
it's i'm not i have a long way to go i
am it doesn't matter i mean just but i
know but let's just as as an argument
like for me it's like
you know they say stop bullying
yeah right which is true stop doing it
but i don't know if i would be in the
place that i'm at now
if i wasn't bullied if i wasn't bullied
yeah but because i'll tell you the one
thing that keeps me going
it's always been fuel for me
i'll show you
you mean even as a kid i remember
getting bullied and going yeah one day
i'll show you yeah but not everyone is
built with that same blueprint i'm just
saying for me specifically yeah i'm not
saying it's good for everyone but i'm
just saying for me
you mean that is like for me to
go to a a coffee shop to do stand-up for
the first time in the mid 90s right it
was like i have to do it to show these
[ __ ] [ __ ] i mean i'm not a [ __ ]
loser you know
i have to win a little bullying a little
bit of childhood trauma gives you good
personality a little bit just give me a
little bit yeah
i think molesting molesting is not good
mm-hmm no never been never never never
been good i feel like because like as a
parent when back then when you're
beating your child because you don't
know any other way to teach them better
you want them to be better and it's it's
disciplining them but molesting is a
solely selfish purpose for their own
sexual gratification so it's never
you know
yeah i mean we talk about this on um on
bloodbath with annie and esther because
we all were raised so differently some
of us were beat more than others one was
not beat at all and we all are [ __ ] up
in our own ways it's just it's a good
experiment to show like basically like
you just never really know how someone's
gonna turn out there's so much more at
play than just
you know your relationship with your
parents even though it is a big part of
it
yeah like i was watching american idol
the other day and there was this guy
named first of all i have to say to katy
perry
i like you you're likeable i think
you're a great you know judge or
whatever but you got this guy wrong all
right i forgot his name but he's sing a
song called the painted man or whatever
oh yeah yeah you remember you saw him i
saw him yeah
and she didn't she
luckily lionel and luke
you know passed him but she's like it's
a gimmick whatever he's doing but then
when he you heard his life story he's
blind in the left eye his parents died
from drug overdose he was by himself the
whole time right he went in there and he
killed it man he was amazing but my
point is is that he doesn't seem like he
came from that kind of lifestyle but he
puts all his you know i mean angst i
guess and his creativity into his music